and family good everyone's great yeah
mom's mom's in England right now dad's
kind of hanging out he just had his
final surgery so he's uh on what well so
he's been kind of laid out for a few
years he he took a fall back in 2019 and
he essentially shattered his cervical
spine he is a like even when I was
working with your mom he he takes did he
take a fall like or I remember he did
the ATV or that yeah that was that was
20 plus years ago he did the ATV crash
20 plus years no yeah old Dad yeah that
was in
200 wait when was that that was
2003 oh wow yeah it's not you were
working with you weren't working with
Sharon I thought I knew right after like
right after you guys started working
together cuz yeah AGT wasn't much and
then he took another fall recently yeah
he took a fall he he missed the bed and
uh he fell like face down on the ground
at night he missed the bed yeah he got
up to pee pitch black you know and just
kind of like stumbled his way thought
the bed was closer than it was missed it
and just face planted and like because
of the quad bike accident he had a bunch
of just vertebrae vertebrae issues and
deterioration after you know cuz when
they put rods and stuff in you like
eventually it starts to kind of wear
things down as you get older because I
saw so he's is he good is he he's he now
after this last surgery they think okay
you're good you can start doing like
lots of phys so and but he can start
doing lots of physio I but you didn't
you post recently that there's a new
album coming out or new music he 24 he
is going to go back in the studio at
some point in the next few months and
and put out another album so that's kind
of that's that's why he's putting a lot
of his
energy